donald trump never gave a penny to his
2020 presidential campaign
but plenty of other people donated even
after trump left the white house in
january
a month after he left office his
campaign committee filed a document
showing it changed its name to the make
america great again pack
and while his supporters kept giving to
the fund trump kept taking money
out of it using his businesses to charge
the group for rent
this is how the former president shifted
thousand 000 from his political donors
to his private businesses after leaving
the white house
according to an analysis of the latest
federal filings
on january 21st the day after his
presidency
ended the trump organization charged
trump's old campaign committee
38 thousand dollars in rent collecting
the money via
trump tower commercial llc trump ran
his 2016 campaign out of offices in the
building
and his 2020 effort operated partially
out of the dc
area but it kept paying rent to trump
tower anyway
now the former president doesn't even
have an official campaign but the rent
payments are still flowing
trump also set up a leadership pack a
fundraising committee that politicians
often use to support candidates named
save america
save america raised more from trump
supporters across the country
building up a war chest of 90 million
dollars by the end of june
and trump drew money from that pot using
his hotel empire to charge save america
another 79 thousand dollars after
leaving office
according to the analysis the leadership
pact paid 19 000
for lodging and meals on march 5th 11
on april 21st and 35 000 on may 12th
mixing in smaller expenses along the way
in total
save america paid the trump hotel
collection 79
thousand 000 after the former president
left the white house
according to the review despite all the
self-dealing
trump's committees still have plenty of
money the former president did not
immediately respond to questions about
the payments
but on saturday he issued a statement
highlighting how his affiliated
committees
have about 100 million dollars of cash
on hand
the statement read quote these
fundraising numbers coupled with
tremendous support in so many other ways
show that the president's supporters
want him to continue the fight